i'm janis dean i'm david asman i'm dana
perino and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday april 14 2021
and lisa brady a tug of war over
policing in america
as some call again for change while
others urge caution
if we want to have an orderly society
there are going to have to be
roles that we expect one another to
follow and there's going to have to be
someone to enforce that
i'm dave anthony we've heard a lot
lately about iran's nuclear threat but
what about north korea aside from a few
missile tests
it's been kind of quiet north korea
typically does something very
provocative in the first year of a u.s
and a south korean administration
so we're expecting that they would do
something big
and i'm dr nicole sapphire i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
the death of dante wright during a
traffic stop arrest in minnesota
has reignited a debate over police
reforms
and anger
protests and riots breaking out over
wright's shooting
which happened in the minneapolis suburb
of brooklyn center
even as a murder trial continues for
former minneapolis
officer derek chauvin in the death of
george floyd
president biden referencing both cases
as he met with the congressional black
caucus on a broader range of issues
tuesday
we're in the business all of us meeting
today to deliver some real change
but spokeswoman jensaki says the
president does not hold the same view
as michigan democratic congresswoman
rashida talib who tweeted that
policing in our country is inherently
and intentionally
racist and can't be reformed saki says
the president's view
is that reforms should be implemented
and accountability
must happen that the loss of life is
far too high that these families are
suffering around
the country and that the black community
is exhausted from the ongoing
threats they feel over the weekend
maryland which was the first state to
approve a police bill of rights decades
ago
became the first state to repeal it the
legislature
overriding vetoes on reforms the
republican governor larry hogan argued
went too far
including new standards for the use of
force limits on no knock warrants
and allowing public access to officers
disciplinary records
there's no more emotional issue in the
public sphere
right now than policing jason johnson is
president of the law
enforcement legal defense fund and
former deputy commissioner of the
baltimore police department
there's really really a lot of public
pressure on on elected officials and
police executives
to act very swiftly when one of these
cases arises and and
and very often uh pressure to act
before there can be any investigation of
what exactly has happened
so these law enforcement officer bill of
rights
do not involve in any way the process of
investigating
whether police actions are criminal in
nature
all they are are protecting officers
with respect to their employment in
other words so that they're they cannot
be
fired without any due process without
any investigation
now more than ever you know police
officers although we
we strongly support improvement in
policing
individual officers need to know that
they at least will get
due process that when there's been an
accusation made and how they've done
their job that there will be some
process where there could be an
investigation to determine the facts
you know in this case that's unfolding
in minnesota
the city manager was just fired you know
within 24 hours of an incident
merely because he suggested that the
officer involved should get due process
not that
she shouldn't be fired or that she
shouldn't be disciplined or even that
she shouldn't be prosecuted but just
that she should receive due process
so if we're going to have an environment
where our law enforcement officers
who we should regard as professionals we
should train them as professionals
and in other ways treat them as
professionals will feel that their jobs
and livelihoods can be taken
merely because they're involved in a
controversial incident without any form
of investigation or due process
we're going to see mass exodus from the
profession
well there are some calls to in essence
do away with policing at least as we
know it um
congresswoman rashida talib tweeting no
more policing she says it's inherently
racist in the u.s and that it can't
be reformed what would you say to her or
others like her
who are thinking the same thing well
it's just not a serious
proposition those kinds of statements
are made with the intent to be
provocative or to play to a certain base
but even since the george floyd protests
and riots of last year
we've seen a change in policing we
haven't seen
uh anything along that scale we have
seen some limited calls to defund and
some
some jurisdictions uh one of those
jurisdictions was portland
oregon which since those calls to defund
has seen a 255 percent
increase in homicides just in in their
jurisdiction
nationwide we've seen it about a 25
increase in homicides during that time
period
um and in cities like you know los
angeles a 50
increase in milwaukee almost 100 percent
increase and i could go on and on down
the list
is that let me let me just ask you one
quick question there on that note though
is is that from funds actually being
taken away or is that a function of
officers sort of pulling back yeah
that's that's largely a function of
officers
recognizing the environment and
understanding that
if they're just involved in a
controversial incident that that could
end their career that could result in
them being charged with a crime
and so forth so it's a result in a sea
change in how policing is done
right now policing is being done in a
much more passive way
whereas i would say pre george floyd in
most cities
policing was an active process where
officers were encouraged to confront
people who they believe were involved in
criminal activity and to follow up on
those leads
and to try to find people illegally
carrying firearms and people who are
repeat offenders and so forth
and now that has changed and so my point
in all that is that when rashida talib
or anyone else suggests that we just do
away with policing
you understand that even limiting the
role of police officers has resulted in
an explosion of murder across the
country and
and i don't have to point out uh this
fact to to any of your listeners that
the the overwhelming majority of those
murder victims
are poor and are black and so um if we
really believe black lives matters we
we need to to gauge our rhetoric
accordingly
and understand that uh policing in many
of these communities
that we're concerned about is vital
to the success of the community what
about former president
obama's call for reimagining policing
and he's not the only one who's used
those words it's kind of a softer tone
than defunding
police is there a way to reimagine
policing then
i think we're all all of our ears are
open to that um i don't know what that
means i i think it's
um naive uh to think
that it again it's sort of it sort of
broadcasts
a signal that police are the problem
you know if there is a problem where
are those problems and what is the
likelihood of of fixing them
you know for example um one of the the
issues that we
we talk about routinely are how police
deal with people with mental illness
well
for for many years now uh police have
been
heavily involved in the business of
honing their response to individuals and
mental health crisis and in partnering
with mental health professionals of
social workers and others
in in some cities there's a dual
response where mental health providers
respond with police officers to these
kinds of
incidents or police officers are
receiving better training
and better equipment and better ways of
defusing and handling
individuals and mental health crisis
that is one success story so
if that's what former president obama
means when he says reimagine policing
i'm completely in line with that on the
other hand
if he means that we should encourage
police officers
to not enforce the law or if we should
repeal
uh much of the criminal code i don't
agree with that
if we want to have an orderly society
there are going to have to be
roles that we expect one another to
follow and there's going to have to be
someone to enforce that
listen if there's a way to make policing
better i think everyone in policing
is open to that but if we're just going
to use
talking points and platitudes that's not
going to solve this problem
this problem is also complicated by some
inherent
disagreements jason johnson says police
use of force in general has been
declining for decades and
that the media's portrayal of an
epidemic of violence
including against african americans is
false
but others argue it's not just about the
actual statistics
there's those interactions that are
reported and they're those interactions
that are unreported
richard fowler is a radio host and fox
news contributor
what the media talks about are the
interactions that are reported
the ones where there's body camera
footage the ones that are
so terrible that we can't look away like
the incidents of george floyd
or the one of dejuan white which which
happened
a couple days ago but there are
instances that happen every day where
even in my own community where i've seen
police officers
raise their voice at children right or
i've seen police officers throw
children on cars or the many instances
that we see happening in our public
schools where police officers are put in
places
to provide discipline to our young
people and i'm not saying
and i'm not an advocate for abolishing
the police
or defunding the police what i'm saying
is we need to create a new contract
when it comes to how policing is done in
this in this country
so that the community is not seen as a
threat but rather the community seen as
a partner
and how we actually create public safety
so the question is
and i know this is like the
million-dollar question
how to make those kinds of reforms
i think we can start very simply uh in
the press conference we saw that took
place in brooklyn center and the mayor
was asked
how many of the police officers that
work in brooklyn center
live in brooklyn center and the mayor's
response was
quite was quite puzzling of the 49
police officers that work in brooklyn
center
zero of them live in that city uh and
that's the brooklyn
brooklyn center's just wanting brooklyn
center minnesota is just one example
of what's happening across the country
right if community if
police officers live in community then
they're going to be more respectful of
the folks they live in they're going to
have a better sense there's going to be
more community between them
and the people that live in that
community right if you live in the
community you work in the community
people know who you are that's one step
the other step
is how do we create better training
protocols right how do we train folks on
implicit bias
how do we train folks on how to deal
with focus how to deal with citizens in
the lgbtqia community
how do we train people on cultural
nuances and cultural norms
and that's just the beginning but it
begins with because it's not just
about policy because in many of these
cases whether it's the case of george
floyd
whether it's a case of eric garner much
of the policy
is against what the police officers did
right i mean the chokehold that was used
against eric garner in staten island is
an illegal chokehold
so it's not that the police department's
written policy is saying that you should
go around and you should choke people to
death
it's how these officers are doing their
jobs in the streets and how we provide
better training to them
so that this doesn't continue to be the
norm of
you can do you could you could do things
without you know
getting punished or do things without
saying hey listen there's consequences
to your actions
congresswoman rashida talib
tweeted out after dante wright's killing
in suburban minneapolis
no more policing that it can't be
reformed i know you've said you're not
an
advocate for abolishing the police or
defunding the police
but do comments like that hurt the
effort
to get police reforms passed i i think
comments like that
are what the media chooses to focus on
instead of focus on the
focusing on the vast majority of folks
who are really actually fighting for
meaningful reform uh case in point we're
talking about rashida talib
and two weeks ago the district of
columbia's police reform commission
released a 30-page report of citizens
who came together
and advocate and citizens and advocates
came together and wrote
a plan on how they want to reform their
police department no mainstream media
outlet
covered it right but it's what that's
what's that they should have covered it
because when citizens
come together with police and say how do
we make this better
how do we end this untenable situation
and how do we actually work together to
create a new contract
that makes everybody feel safe and
actually restores
trust between community and police and
actually
allows the police to trust to protect
and serve the community
and the community not feel fearful about
their interactions policing
but instead what ends up happening is we
focus on one tweet from one
congresswoman instead of the work that's
happening in cities across america
where mayors and and community members
are coming together and they're trying
to find ways to make the situation
better
richard fowler radio host fox news
contributor
always grateful for your time thanks so
much thank you
this is dr nicole sapphire with your fox
news commentary coming up
iran has been a big issue with the u.s
trying to rejoin the international
nuclear deal but
this past weekend's attack at an iranian
facility complicated things with
iran blaming israel vowing revenge and
planning to increase uranium enrichment
closer to weapons grade levels but
what about north korea president biden
recently told reporters
it remains his top foreign policy issue
after two missile
tests there will be responses if they
choose to escalate
the president added he's open to
diplomacy but it has to be
conditioned upon the end result of
denuclearization but there's no detailed
policy plan yet
we don't really know what the policy is
yet
but i think there's some knowns and some
unknowns bruce klingner used to be the
deputy cia division chief for korea now
a senior research fellow at the heritage
foundation
the knowns would be that biden and
others have already said they're going
to go back to sort of a traditional
u.s policy or diplomacy
approach of a bottom up where you
have to have progress at diplomatic
level working level meetings
with north korea towards an actual
denuclearization agreement
uh before you get rewarded with having a
summit and that's
what administrations of both parties
have been doing for
for decades he's also said that there
will be
continued focus on denuclearization
rather than arms control which some
korea experts are advising you know the
two things we don't know
yet are what would be the parameters of
an acceptable agreement for the biden
administration
with north korea and the second is how
firmly will they
enforce not only u.n resolutions but u.s
laws so
previous administrations of both parties
have underachieved even on fully
enforcing our own laws so
those are the things that i'll be
looking for whenever they unveil the
policy
all right we haven't even heard much
from north korea regarding the u.s
except for how kim jong-un's
sister put out some sort of a statement
uh warning
the biden administration not to cause a
stink
whatever they mean by that and if and if
they
but if they do they wouldn't be able to
sleep in peace for the next four years
so
that typical rhetoric yeah it is
uh what they've said in the last several
years
which was consistent with previous ones
is basically you know
we're not interested in dialogue with
you unless you give us what we want
throughout 2019 they said that their
patience is running out with the
the us that uh that the their
self-imposed
moratorium on nuclear and icbm tests uh
which was irrelevant because they're
required not to do any kind of tests
uh uh under unle resolutions
you know that their patients would end
and sometime in 2020 they would do
something dire though unspecified
and then they didn't do anything and
that might have been because of of covid
and north korea typically does something
very provocative in the first year of a
u.s
and a south korean administration so
we're expecting that they would do
something big
we have seen them do a couple of
different missile tests in recent
weeks they were sort of back to back in
a matter of days
one was the short range the other was
long range right
well what they did was uh two different
tests one was cruise missiles which were
short range
and because they're cruise missiles
they're not a violation of u.n
resolutions and then a couple days later
they did two short-range ballistic
missiles and because they were ballistic
those are violations of the u.n
resolutions
all right what is the difference because
i don't know if everybody knows the
difference between those two missiles
cruise and ballistic
right well a cruise missile sort of you
know goes in a straight line
as it were in a ballistic missile kind
of goes in a parabola like if you
throw a high fly baseball it sort of
goes up on a trajectory and then comes
down and
okay the the un resolutions they
identify
uh restrictions not by the range of a
missile but
by whether it uses quote ballistic
missile technology
end quote president trump had two
approaches to north korea
first insulting kim jong-un calling him
rocket man threatening to annihilate the
country and then
he tried to make friends our
unprecedented meeting the first between
an
american president and a leader of north
korea
proves that real change is indeed
possible
saying at their first summit in 2018
chairman kim and i just signed a joint
statement in which he reaffirmed his
unwavering commitment to complete
denuclearization
of the korean peninsula but that didn't
happen and president trump walked out of
their second summit months later
no there was no progress towards
denuclearization
at least it tested the hypothesis that
some people had put forward where they
tended to blame the united states for
the impasse
and saying that well in north korea
given the very hierarchical
system they have only kim jong-un can
make decisions so
if only the u.s would deign to have a
meeting between the u.s and north korea
leader then
then everything would be solved well we
tried that and it
didn't show to be any more successful
than the previous approaches so
uh you know regardless of political
party or administration in the u.s the
the common denominator for the lack of
progress or lack of success on
denuclearization
has always been pyongyang it's it's
always they're the ones that have either
cheated on agreements or not fulfilled
what they promised to do you referenced
covid the north koreans have been
claiming
there isn't a single coronavirus case in
that country that they've been able to
ward off covet somehow
what i mean obviously the country's shut
off it's hard to get in there
what do you know about the coronavirus
in that country
well i think it's pretty laughable that
they claim they haven't had a single
case and then
uh what happened a few months ago is a a
north korean who had defected to the
south
redefected to the north uh and what they
were going to do was blame him for every
single covet case that
occurred in north korea had they
admitted to it but um
anyway so they did impose really drastic
uh anti-covet restrictions so
they even cut off uh really all foreign
trade including the
90 or so that they trade with with china
uh they even cut off their
state-sponsored
smuggling that they do to evade u.n
sanctions
uh so it's had you know an impact on
their economy
um so we think they do have cases we
think they've had
you know cases we think they've had
deaths perhaps not as big as we
thought they might have had given the
the emaciated condition of their
populace as well as the
really minimalist conditions of their
hospitals and medical system but
certainly they've had cases but not you
know as bad as it could have been had
they not done those draconian measures
but
you know it did have quite an impact on
their on their economy
there was a lot of this wild speculation
back in 2020 that
the kim jong-un was sick or or maybe
even died because his sister was somehow
more prominent he wasn't seen for a
while
what happened do you know so
back when kim's father died uh you know
even the cia didn't know he had died
for a couple days until north korea
announced he had died so
you know information on the leader is is
very difficult to get in north korea
because they keep it very tightly
you know held so you know we were saying
look he may be dead
um or he you know may come back and you
know i think it was just he was being
very cautious about kobit we think he
went out to a
sort of a remote villa of his and uh you
know and then he came back i mean he's
obviously not the picture of health
given his weight and medical conditions
but
you know he came back looking fairly
healthy and robust so we don't think he
had actually been sick
how good is north korea at
cyber espionage you know actually
very very good i'm just finishing
research on a project and
even though i've been covering north
korea for many years
i was amazed at how expansive
and good they are um you know people
tend to think of well north korea is
this backward little country they
couldn't possibly
either come up with you know workable
nuclear weapons or missiles that
can hit the entire continental us which
they can uh
or cyber and i remember back in 2014
when
uh sony was hacked because of that movie
called the interview which made fun of
kim jong-un
right right and over the years u.s and
south korean officials have said
north korea's in the top three or four
countries in the world
uh they've gotten into very secure u.s
and south korean government and
and military computers they've stolen
our war plans they've stolen
uh south korean defense technology uh
now in recent years they've shifted to
cyber bank robbery
and then also going after virtual
currency like bitcoin and stuff
uh the un panel of experts estimates
they've gotten at least two billion
dollars
in bank robberies and cyber exchanges
and and that is
likely an underestimate we don't see a
lot of pictures of north korea
people and places several years ago some
ap
journalists spent a week there traveling
the country with state sensors by their
side
taking some rather stark photos
reporting that throughout north korea
fewer than 500 miles of roads are paved
north korea occasionally lets
journalists in and then
in many cases they sort of decide okay
do we want to
take them on the things are looking
great to her or do we want to show them
that things are looking dire to her
uh so if they're trying to elicit
donations of humanitarian assistance you
know they may take them to the
you know to the schools where the poor
children are starving
um or the hospitals that don't have you
know
supplies or medical equipment you know
or they may
uh take them on the things are looking
great tour where it's like
so you know your sanctions are
meaningless to us we are strong we are
robust etc
and and i think someone even pointed out
once where the
random person in the street that they
the journalists interviewed
was actually the same random guy in the
street that some other journalists had
interviewed you know a couple months
earlier yeah and then this particular
thing if you go through the gallery of
all the pictures
they they none of the people they saw
they didn't even react to what they were
seeing even though they probably had
never seen an american before
they didn't even react probably because
they feared a reaction right
very much they you know the people that
would interact
even quote unquote randomly with foreign
journalists
you know either are a plant or they
would be
very concerned about any kind of
thing that they said to a foreigner
because they know they're probably going
to get a visit by the security service
or even just they're innately suspicious
of foreigners the
the koreans are the north koreans are
taught from an
early age that the us uh
is the enemy so you know even elementary
school math problems are things like if
i kill three americans and you kill two
americans how many americans have we
killed
are you serious yeah and you know
they're wow
they're taught just very early on that
you know
the americans are the enemy that the
americans have done terrible things in
the past to them including during the
korean war that
you know we're out to get them that the
the reason for the hardship in north
korea
is as they say you know because of the
the
hostile policy of the u.s and things
would be great if only those
americans would stop treating them so
badly so they tend to use this
uh you know the the main enemy threat as
a way of justifying the harsh conditions
that
the populist is suffering and also to
justify
the the very high percentage of their
budget that they put towards the
military
they also put a high part of the budget
on sort of glorification of the leader
of these thousands of statues throughout
the country and
occasional huge massive uh
demonstrations in a stadium with
thousands of people
you know putting on shows synchronized
dancing etc so
uh yeah it's you know in a way they need
the enemy
as a way of justifying both the failure
of
their economy and the reason why they
put so much into their military
very interesting indeed bruce klingner
senior research fellow for northeast
asia at the heritage foundation
thank you very much for joining us well
thanks for having me
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa
just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it
on demand from fox news and amazon alexa
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
dr
nicole sapphire what's on your mind
throughout the pandemic media and
technology companies have impulsively
discredited some narratives while
prematurely promoting others
by some strange coincidence these
decisions almost uniformly align with
left-wing policy objectives
last week youtube removed a video of a
recent roundtable discussion between
florida governor ron desantis
and several doctors and epidemiologists
known for their anti-lockdown opinions
the panel convened to discuss florida's
covet 19 response
with desantis and others criticizing the
overall u.s response while discussing
the unintended consequences
that have resulted from prolonged
lockdowns math squaring
and school closures when the wall street
journal asked about the removal
youtube provided an example of a comment
by dr j
bhattacharya a stanford university
professor of medicine
and research associate at the national
bureau of economic research
who said masking for children is
developmentally inappropriate
youtube further gave the reason for the
video's removal as
because it included content that
contradicts the consensus
of local and global health authorities
regarding the efficacy of mass
to prevent the spread of covet 19.
but even that statement is untrue put
simply
there is very little local or global
consensus on many facets of the pandemic
particularly children wearing mass
without diving too
deep into the minutia while the centers
for disease control and prevention may
recommend
mask wearing in children over two the
world health organization does not
the who says children age five years and
under should not be required to wear
mass
and that for children six to eleven
years of age the potential impact of
wearing a mask
on learning and psychosocial development
in consultation with teachers
parents caregivers and or medical
providers
should be considered before having them
wear mass
so while comments arguing against
children wearing mass
may go against dr anthony fauci and
other scientific purists with the
singular mission of eradicating a virus
it does not go against other equally
reputable sources that emphasize
kids wearing face masks may disrupt
their development
reasonable experts can and do disagree
it is this discord that fuels
trial and error experimentation and
discovery
science by its very nature is rarely
settled
in the race for information about the
novel virus technology and media
companies have jumped ahead to help
shape narratives around partisan
policies despite the science changing by
the day
big tech is collecting massive amounts
of data while stifling free speech
and removing content that goes against
popular opinion
in a public health crisis such as we are
still in
it is essential to have transparent
discussions on responses and outcomes
to help lay a better path for the future
it should not be acceptable for youtube
and facebook to ban
content that conflicts with a certain
party's policy enactments
while vaccine hesitancy remains a
barrier in vaccination efforts
suppressing contrarian views on twitter
and elsewhere only adds to the growing
skepticism
banning discussion misinformation or not
does not change the reality that
legitimate debate on the subject exists
there is no party of science whether we
like the conclusions or not
whether we feel comfortable debating the
ambiguity or not
the outcomes speak the truth suppression
efforts do more to discredit and
undermine science than conservatism
and that's dangerous i'm nicole sapphire
medical contributor for fox news and
author of the book
panic attack i wrote this piece in
collaboration with former congressman
jason chaffetz
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes